Good morning, John. I woke up this morning at nine o'clock.
This is me looking at myself in the Viewscreen and thinking, "My hair is a bird,"
"your argument is invalid." Then I went for a run.
And I looked at some fish and then because it was so frackin hot and humid, I jumped into a pool. I'm in Florida.
It's very hot everywhere. The air isn't "conditioned". Blow your frigid air of sweet salvation.
And because the inside is so preferable to the outside, no one is outside. Everyone is stuck in their
4,000 cubic foot SUVs, and that includes me. The people at Enterprise rental car excitedly announced that I was getting a
"quadruple upgrade" to a "real big truck". It is indeed real big, though in Montana,
we don't call something a truck unless you can throw a bull elk in the back of it.
I'd call this thing a boat before I call it a truck.
I lived here most of my life, and then having moved away,
I realized that there were a lot of things wrong with it.
Now, I'm realizing that I kind of had a rather selective negative memory about this place
Yes, it is unnecessarily hot. Yes,
the sun is
ridiculously bright.
Can somebody turn this down? The cars are big and you need to have one all the time to get anywhere. All the cups are made
of styrofoam and the fire ants...yeah, the fire ants are bad. You should not go poke fire ant mounds because
Well, wow yeah, okay? Yeah? I got stung, but I can't really say I didn't deserve that one, but there are also things
I love. Sweet tea, Waffle House, and that giant insane sun breeds a
humongous variety of life that we just can't compare with in Montana. And sure the humidity will suck away your will to live, but sometimes
it's nice to have a reason to jump into a giant pool of water.
But now that the sun is going down and the temperature is approaching
bearable, at least, I realize that the reason I feel like I miss Florida now isn't because I miss Florida,
it's because I missed the reason that I'm here right now.
And I'm here to watch a friend get married, and so of course all of my old college friends from Florida are also here to
watch my friend get married.
It's a reunion of sorts, several people who I haven't seen in almost 10 years.
Which is how long it has been since I graduated from college which is extraordinarily
upsetting. Most of the best reasons to love a place are people. And when I walked out of the Tallahassee regional airport and the thick,
hot air was blowing
through the palm trees, the thing I think about first isn't the traffic, or the sprawl.
It's actually the reason why I had to walk away from the pool, because I didn't want my friends to hear me get all sappy
about this stuff.
But the reason I love Florida is because of the people
who I loved when I was here, and who I will of course keep on loving forever. John, I'll see you on Wednesday.
The fries are tiny too. The fries are tiny, cuz they're Steak and Shake fries.
Off camera: The fries have not changed at all.
Okay
Off camera: Oh, oh, he did it, wow. That was two bites.
Off camera: There was look compression
Off camera: Don't die.
Off camera: Like a snake swallowing an egg.